Jonathan starts up this hour and Fort
Smith Arkansas hi Jonathan how are you
I'm doing good Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up well my
question is on whether or not to sell my
house right now I'm on a pause baby step
two in school part-time and I'm a single
dad and I work part-time as much as I
can and I'm just finding that I'm having
trouble keeping up my house is paid off
so don't have a house payment but just
with the regular expenses that come with
a house I'm just not able to keep up I'm
trying to figure out how I should sell
or not and just wait till I get out of
school I am planning on selling it
within the next 18 months because I'm
planning on getting married or that's
what it looks like in the next 18 months
or so cool when do you graduate from
school I will graduate not this fall but
the fall after that okay and so a little
over so about 18 months for that as well
yeah pretty close I'll well I'm I'm
thinking we'll get married next summer
and then that fall I will be graduating
that December I guess got you okay and
what's your degree in history education
my long-term goal is to be a professor
to get my doctorate in history okay and
how are you going to pay for all of that
well I'll have my four-year degree which
I can teach in Arkansas they have
programs where you can teach in a high
school and the high school will pay for
your master's degree because they get
more funding if you're more qualified
got it
and I think this has a couple of years
you have to work for them and then the
PhD would just be out of pocket yeah so
you'll be a history teacher what does
what is your potential fiance do she's
in school right now getting a biology
degree but she's thinking about she's
just now finishing up her second year
she's thinking about switching majors
because if she's gonna switch she has to
switch now but she's wanting to
potentially be a biologist and she might
switch to writing so she's
conflicted on that right now okay yeah
let's think about a career choice of
what we're gonna do for a living after
studying for four years okay that that's
realistic and that that makes sense so
what's the house worth I talked to Annie
LP and he believed that after what I
will get is about 30,000 that will get
more I'm saying we'll get you out of
school yes sir right right now I'm able
to keep up with just bills I mean
daycare is eating me alive it's 120
dollars a week in my bills for a week or
about 300 so that's you know over a
third mm-hmm but I'm able to keep up
with just a week-to-week regular
expenses but like the heating and air
went out and I need a whole new unit
which is $3,000 and I just have no way
to there's no way you know mm-hmm
there's no way at this point to do that
okay
and it's February yeah yeah well I have
I have I have space heaters now and I
bought some nice space heaters but
that's getting us through for now yeah
okay
sell it I'm with you okay yeah this
house house is no longer a blessing it
is not congruent with your future goals
and so what we want to do is align your
future goals we want to get you married
get you to being a history teacher and
paying your bills and eating taking care
of your kid and getting her graduated
and into a career that's that's
lucrative and so on so yeah that's
exactly what I would do I would sell it
you're not gonna live there it's not
your long-term plan it helps you get to
your long-term plans there's no reason
to keep it yes sir okay now when you
ramp when you rent rent the cheapest
thing you can rent yes sir would I mean
what I I kind of have a problem being a
25 year old able-bodied person doing
this but with low-income housing be
something to look at or would they mean
morally would that be okay I don't know
I did morally okay I don't need to I
mean you got 3,000 bucks in your hand
you only got to make it 18 months till
you graduate get your teaching
certificate and go to work and so you
know and when you don't have this house
to deal with all the time you may be
able to work more even sure sure you
know so you know you don't you've got
you can rent something inexpensive in
Fort Smith Arkansas for you and your son
you don't have to rent the something
super fancy it is it's an adventure for
18 months because it's probably not even
where you're gonna live you're probably
move again after you're married yes sir
yes sir that's what we plan on play on
doing yeah so is she working now yes sir
she works at her family in the business
hometown she works part-time at good
okay very good
what kind of business they run a skating
rink a roller skating rink okay cool
I imagine you can pick up some hours
over there too cause you need all them
income you can get right now and your
kid can hang out at the roller skating
rink that wouldn't be bad at all so and
you get to see your fiance so anything
you can do like that man anything we can
do to add to this equation this is a
short period of your life it's not going
to be like this for long and you'll be
you know two years from now three years
from now things are gonna be completely
different so everybody's gonna be fine
but yes I would use the proceeds from
the house to set you up to win over the
next two to three years